let's bring in our panel steve hilton is
a former advisor british prime minister
david cameron and host of the next
revolution here on fox news channel MOA
lee the executive director of the
georgetown Institute of Politics and
byron york chief political correspondent
of the washington examiner byron it
didn't get a ton of coverage today but i
think the prospect of this becoming a
major thing in the middle east could be
big yeah and the question is what does
it have to do what's with what has just
happened and with the Iran deal but it
clearly Iran and Israel have been
conducting a shadow war in this area for
quite a while and it's been getting
worse and worse and worse I think what
was striking was the reaction of the
Trump administration a very very strong
message in support of Israel not only
affirming Israel's supporting going
fighting back but it's right to fight
back and defend itself so I think we saw
and also just the Sarah Huckabee Sanders
soundbite we just heard about Iran I
think we've heard a very different
message out of this White House than the
previous one
know in the wake of the Iran nuclear
deal decision it seems like the prospect
of this happening is is greater I think
that's right and I think that's what a
lot of our European allies were were
worried about that this I agree with by
where there's been this this shadow war
that's being fought and there was a lot
of concern from European allies that by
walking away from the deal it might
stoked tensions just enough to make that
shadow war bubble up into up to the
surface and make it more intense I don't
think anyone questions Israel's right to
defend itself I think we all stand with
Israel but you know you heard from our
European allies today halls please for a
level of measured response that we do
not allow this thing to escalate as it's
so easily could and try to bring
everyone back to the negotiating table
to find a new deal but on the flip side
Steve on the Iran deal it Iran was not
spending on infrastructure projects in
Tehran or filling the potholes they were
obviously investing in military
operations in Syria
and funding Hezbollah with a lot of that
money exactly right and in in a way you
couldn't have asked for a better
justification for what the president did
with the Iran deal it proved the point
that that actually Iran is a an
aggressive war mongering regime it wants
to control the whole region for a long
time now
the policy of the US and the European
allies and others has been appeasement
essentially saying if we talk to you and
we give you money and we support you
then maybe you'll change your ways that
hasn't happened and so now we're in a
new world where the policy is to stand
up to the bully to confront the bully
and that is not comfortable it's not
easy and you can see that the Allies are
in Europe are getting nervous but their
policy has failed to contain Iran Europe
are also not the only allies in the
whole world to be concerned about theirs
the Egyptians
there's the Saudis there's the Amorites
I mean there are a lot of other people
in the world who have a big stake in
this I think you support what the United
States is doing here all right let's
talk about this big moment overnight
we've covered it the three Americans
coming home from North Korea and the
question was who gets credit and how
much North Korea credit is there now
that this summit is set in place here's
the president and the Senate Minority
Leader
the exultation by the president and
others of the greatness of North Korea
doing this evades me we can't be fooled
into giving the North Korean regime
credit for returning Americans that
never should have been detained in the
first place
American citizens are not diplomatic
bargaining chips what about that Steve
this reminds me so much of one of the
fundamental mistakes I think that
president Trump's critics make over and
over and over again they focus almost
entirely on his words his performance
there almost like TV critics rather than
political analysts and they ignore the
substance okay sometimes he says words
that wouldn't be considered diplomatic
and in the normal kind of parlance of
politics but he gets the results and
they focus on the superficial and ignore
the fact that he's actually making real
progress well it's way too early to know
whether or not he's making progress on
North Korea the North Koreans the North
Korean dictator seized American citizens
two of which under this administration
under this president and returned them
today
just as we're about to head into a
summit I am hopeful I am a Democrat but
I am hopeful that our president is
successful in this summit but there are
many flags here there are many things
that we need to be concerned about and
that this North Korean dictator is
looking to be seen as an equal of the
United States when you look at the
comments he has been making it isn't
about he's promising to stop nuclear
testing why because he believes that
their nuclear tests already successful
enough he says the total
denuclearization of the peninsula that
means for the United States to so I hope
the president can go and if he can
negotiate something successful with the
North Koreans I will be among the first
to applaud him but there are a lot of
red flags here and I worry I worry that
the North Korean dictator is playing him
a little bit June 12th Singapore we
obviously don't know the details and the
devil
we'll be in the details but a month ago
a lot of people in this town we're
saying we're headed to war with North
Korea absolutely first of all the June
12th and Singapore means it's more
likely to happen remember there's a lot
of talk about how it would not happen
but also can we just say that the
release of the three Americans is great
news I mean it's good news for them it's
good news for the United States and it
is good news for for Donald Trump so
even in it's not conditional on the
success of the North Korean talks if
they don't succeed just like they've
never succeeded before this is still
just good news in itself yes